ich war drei tage an der nation schaut
euch meine nase an
allerdings ist abgesehen von einem
sonnenbrand auf der nase den letzten
tagen noch etwas anderes verheerendes
passiert ich finde mich gerade weil
wieder in meinen movistar planet account
reingegangen habe dort diese nachricht
vorgefunden du hast gegen die regeln
verstoßen indem du unangemessene sachen
gesagt hast oder sachen gesagt hast die
andere nutzer verletzten wirklich das
einzige hallo ich bin ein einsames
hässliches opfer als wir sollen uns auf
jeden fall höflich benehmen und das
werde ich nur noch machen also wir
klicken jetzt mal hier auf das kreuzchen
drauf bitte beachte die regeln okay er
kam noch mal ein zwei mal gegen die
regeln verstoßen auffällig egal meine
frau wurde hatte ich da wo ich jetzt
erstmal recht herzlich begrüßen die
heute zu einer weiteren episode
dapd
hallo ich bin holly der star reporterin
hollywood möchte dein freund sein
möchtest du auch
nein ich bin doch schon die star
reporterin elefant mit seinem neuen
place wetter waren fashion idole
ich würde sagen wir bewegen uns direkt
mal wieder in den chat bereiche vorne
und schauen uns hier mal die orte an wir
waren noch nicht im einkaufscenter davon
aber auch erst ab level 8
scheiß auf mein abi scheiße auf mein
abgeschlossenes studium ich bin level 17
mobistar blender
wir befinden uns jetzt im
einkaufszentrum jetzt auf jeden fall
mega die hölle los
hier kommen grad mehr und mehr leute
rein hier ist der james beispielsweise
der der gebrochene wangen reiches golfen
[Musik]
erdreiches grill 500 wie geht's dir hmd
ellguth dir was heißt h mdl habe ich mit
gerlinde dass es zwischen uns hab dich
lieb reiches girl 500
[Musik]
hahaha ich werde fan aber hahaha ich
hatte noch nie so viel spaß bei so einem
vergangenen spiel jetzt schreibt sie
einfach oder auch hashtag hash der
crashtest besteckhersteller luca fleisch
3.0 video schreiben die hier schon warum
schreibt ihr jetzt bei dem allerdings
kalt duschen soll das mich erst
beleidigt und jetzt ich geh weg aus
michael drewes mit viel zu komisch da
als wir waren schon am strand am
einkaufszentrum das heißt wir gehen
jetzt mal den haustierpark ich weiß
nicht ob man dieser chat raum erfordert
dem besitz eines haustieres haben
das lassen wir dann glaube ich ein paar
sekunden später
teamgeist ist gerade mein raum gegangen
[Musik]
da würde ich mal guckt wieder auswärts
ist also keine ahnung was hier plötzlich
abgeht m ich bin hier einfach gerade in
elefanten als raum gegangen das ist
quasi so mein zimmer also so wie bei
sims so das eigene haus da kann man
leute in einladen und die sehen sich
dann den rebound und so also das hier ja
ach hallo yoko ono 76 ist auch dann ein
ganz deutschland
was willst du hier das ist meinen raum
sind auch nicht so dass ich meine
forderung ist und dann gehe ich jetzt
hier auf meinem zimmer haus entstehen da
zehn leute und einen geist auf einem
elefanten plane plötzlich aber gut dass
ich jetzt auf jeden fall einer meiner
räume wir können auch noch mal auf küche
klicken das ist ja das sind meine
küchengeräte dann habe ich natürlich
selbstverständlich auch noch einen
partyraum zebrafell auf dem boden und
leoparden gefälle an den wänden und dann
habe ich natürlich selbstverständlich
auch noch einen garten da kann ich auch
mal drauf klicken der ist ja mein garten
ist ein fachanwalt ich glaube der
wichtigste raum ist allerdings wirklich
das wohnzimmer wo der geist
selbstverständlich noch immer am tanzen
ist du kannst echt schlecht tanzen der
geist hat sich verwandelt
aha jetzt sich in deine karre ist halt
in meinem wohnzimmer gerade ein teppich
kannst du dann gern sauber machen aber
der war den scheibenwischern alter du
bist in meinem fucking wohnzimmer raus
aus meinem raum mit einer schrottkarre
princess 006 geträumt hallo inzest an
006 max du tust brot
ich habe aber den besten tochter der
stadt zustimmt habe gerade geduscht
werbegesicht also kann ja nicht sein
dass diese prinzessin 006 einfach in
meinen raum rein kommt und sagt ich
stinke okay wer hat geschrieben okay
kann man leute aus den eigenen raum
rausschmeißen also keine ahnung wie das
hier funktioniert wichtig einfach mal
hier drauf blockt das ist locken
princess 006 ball so dass hier sieht es
tut mir leid wirklich aber dass das
nicht stimmt also ich musste
konsequenzen ziehen
allerdings will ich an der stelle das
heutige movies da blendet video jetzt
auch beenden am main raum das ist gerade
eine reinste party da irgendwie keine
ahnung wo die ganzen menschen da
plötzlich herkommen aber falls euch das
heutige video der dritte teil movistar
plänen ich weiß nicht warum diese
jährige lacht flash heißt du musst sagen
dass diese zeit sagt das heutige video
gefallen hat dann lasst unbedingt einen
daumen hoch unter dem video hier da
schreibt mir außerdem unten in die
kommentare ob ihr wollt dass ich in
einer woche den vierten teil movistar
planet hochladen abonniert main kanal
damit ihr das dann nicht verpasst
[Musik]